[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم في
الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث وتتفاعل
اخرى البدايه من رام الله والمناسبه
الصعيد جديد من جانب قوات الاحتلال في
مناطق مختلفه من الضفه الغربيه
للشعب الفلسطيني
في ولايه النيل الازرق الجنوبي السودان
هناك وقعت المكونات الاجتماعيه اتفاقا
للتعايش السلمي ونبذ العنف القبلي الذي
اود بحياتي كثيرين في الاشهر الماضيه
وهذه الصور تريدنا مباشره من واشنطن اثر
اعلان البيت الابيض ولايتين ارباما
وكاليفورنيا منطقتي كوارث جره فيضانات
والسيول في اجزاء مختلفه من البلاد منذ
اسبوعين
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
بعد اعلانها السيطره على سوليدار القوه
الروسيه تركز هجماتها على باخ موت شرقي
اوكرانيا بوتين يقول ان العمليات العسكريه
تسير وفق الخطط النيتو يعلن ان دول غربيه
سترسل المزيد من الاسلحه الثقيله لقياس
ويصف المرحله الحاليه من الحرب بالحاسمه
اسرائيل تواصل التصعيد في الضفه الغربيه
قوات الاحتلال تقتل فلسطينيا من المسافه
صفر قرب رام الله اشتباكات مسلحه بين
فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال في يعبد في جنين
تعزيزات عسكريه للاحتلال وموجه اعتقالات
في الخليل بعد اطلاق مسلحين النار على
حافله للمستوطنين
بعد يوم من مظاهرات حاده للمعارضه في تونس
اتحاد الشغل يحذر من انتفاضه شعبيه بسبب
ما سماه سياساته غير وطنيه للحكومات
المتعاقده ويقترح مناقشه انتخابات رئاسيه
مبكرا وتعديل الدستور ضمن مبادره لحل
الازمه السياسيه وصوت من الرئاسه حيال
المبادره
في اول اجتماع لها بعد تعثر دام اشهر
اللجنه العسكريه المشتركه في ليبيا خمسه
زائد خمسه تبحث تكوين قوه مشتركه بين
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه وقوات حفتر ومصادر
ليبيه تكشف للجزيره عن ان مدير السي اي اي
شدد خلال زيارته الى ليبيا على عدم
المساسي بموانئ النفط او بتصديره
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا توقيعه مكونات النيل
الازرق الاجتماعيه اتفاقا للتعايش السلمي
ينص على نفذ العنف ووقف خطاب الكراهيه
والعنصريه والجهويه ويعتبر اتفاق جوبا
مرجعيه لحل النزاعات القبليه ويقضي
الاتفاق ايضا بانشاء نيابات ومحاكم خاصه
بالعنف القبلي الذي اودى بحياه اكثر من
200 شخص في ولايه النيل الازرق بين يوليو
واكتوبر الماضيه باستطاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
في رايكم كيف سنعكس اتفاق التعايش السلمي
على مشهد النزاعات القبليه في ولايه النيل
الازرق 11% قالوا انه سيضع حدا لها بين ما
قال 22% انه سيسهم في حلها وراء
67% ان الاتفاق الجديد لن يغير شيئا
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكن دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقاءنا
يتجدد يوميا ونغترق خلاله قضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربي ودوليه
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
في اسوا كارثه جويه في النيبال منذ 30
عاما 68 قتيلا افرى تحطم طائره قبل دقائق
من هبوطها بواسطه البلاد
[موسيقى]
قالت القوه الاوكرانيه انها تتصدت
لمحاولات روسيه للتقدم في محور مدينه
باخموت وبثت صورا لمقاتلين شيشان كانوا
يتصدون لقوات فاجنر بعد ان حاولت التسلل
الى مواقع في بلده في بلده جنوب شرق مخموت
وبين ما قال قياده الميدانيه الاوكرانيه
للجزيره ان الاعلان الروسي بشان السيطره
غير صحيح تصر القوات الروسيه على اخبار
تقدمها حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تحقيقه تقدم في الضواحي الشماليه لمدينه
يتصاعد القتال حول باخموت في اعقاب
السيطره الروسيه على سوريدار المجاوره
تستخدم القوات الاوكرانيه صواريخ جراند
سعيا لصد التقدم الروسي باتجاه المدينه
التي تقع على مسافه قريبه جدا جنوب غرب
سوليدار التي سقطت للتو في يد الجانب
الروسي ميدانيا تعد السوليدار مفتاح باخمت
وكلتاهما ميدانيا وفق عسكريا تشكلان نقطه
الضعف الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه دونيتك التي
يستميت الروس لسيطره عليها كما ان بخمت
تحديدا نقطه تقاطع هامه لخطوط سكك حديديه
وطرق معبده وتعطي السيطره عليها فرصه
كبيره لروسيا للتمدد في مقاطعه
قياده العمليات الاوكرانيه قالت ان قواتها
تصدت لمحاولات روسيه للتقدم في محور
باخمود وقالت انها تحافظ على مواقعها
وتعزز خطوطها الدفاعيه في المدينه التي
استردتها من الروس قبل اسابيع قليله في
المقابله تحدثت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن
نجاحات في الضواحي الشماليه لبخمت وقال
بيانها اليومي ان عشارات الجنود
الاوكرانيين قتلوا فضلا عن تدمير عربات
قتاليه ومدرعات ما زال الجانب الروسي
منتشيا للسيطره التي اعلنها على سردار عبر
ميليشيا فاجنر التي تباها قائدها بقواته
وكفاءتها وتسليحها الفائق يتوقع ميدانيا
نفخ خبراء عسكريين ان تتحرك عناصر فاجنر
من سوليدار الى باخمت هي الان تتمركز جنوب
المدينه ويتوقع ان تهاجم ايضا من الشمال
لان الدفاعات الاوكرانيه متاهبه جنوبا
نشرت القوات الاوكرانيه والصور لمقاتلين
كيشان حلفاء لها كانوا يتصداون لجنود من
فاجنر حاولوا التسلل الى مواقع الجيش
الاوكراني جنوب شرقي ضخمه التي مازال
الاوكرانيون ينفون صحه انباء تتحدث عن
وقوعها تحت الحصار
بعيدا عن جبهات الشرق افادت السلطات
المحليه في دينيبرو بارتفاع حصيله قتل
القصف الروسي امس على بنايه سكنيه الى 29
قتيلا اضافه الى ثلاثه جارحه قالت السلطات
وان عمليات الانقاذ لا تزال مستمره وان
مصير اكثر من 40 شخصا لا يزال مجهوله
ومع اقتراب الحرب من انهاء عامها الاول
تحاول اوكرانيا الحصول على اسلحه من الغرب
تمكنها من قلب المعادله على الارض في
تقرير التالي نتعرف على ابرز الاحتياجات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه
لم تحسم المعركه في اوكرانيا
مضاده تمنع كليهما من الحسد ولكنه ترفع
الصوت عاليا للمطالبه من الاسلحه النوعيه
من الارض
ترتكز المطالب الاوكرانيه
والصواريخ بعيده المدى والاسلحه المضاده
للدبابات
والمدرعات بانواعها والطائرات المسيره
تحاول القوه الاوكرانيه سحب بساط الجو من
روسيا وتلك نقطه ضعف الرئيسيه بالنسبه
للقوات الاوكرانيه لكن الامر بحاجه الى
منظومات متناسقه وتنوع في المستويات
لتناسب الصواريخ المعاديه فمثلا لا يمكن
استخدام صاروخ من منظومه
تكلفته الى ثلاثه ملايين دولار لاسقاط
الطائره المسيره لا تصل تكلفتها الى
20,000 دولار لذلك تستخدم انظمه
لمواجهه الصواريخ الفرد صوتيه بسبب الفرق
في السرعه لصالح صاروخ باتريوت بينما تسقط
الطائره المسيره بصواريخ قصيره المدى او
رشاشات ثقيله وهذا امر تعاني منه اوكرانيا
مع التفوق الروسي في الاجواء الاوكرانيه
تحتاج القوات الاوكرانيه كذلك الى صواريخ
بعيده المدى كانت منظمه هيمارس الامريكيه
قد دخلت على المعادله فاثبتت كفاءه عاليه
وحيدت الامداد اللوجستيه للروس في المناطق
الجنوبيه والشرقيه تلك الصواريخ التي
تخدمت وصل مداها الى 80 كم لكن من هذه
الصواريخ ما يصل مداه الى 160 او 300 كيلو
متر ما يعني يدا طول للقوه الاوكرانيه في
ضرب العمق الروسي وشبه جزر القمر اما في
العمليات البريه فان القوات الاوكرانيه
بحاجه لاسلحه مضاده للدبابات ومنها بشكل
اساسي صواريخ جافل وان لو وكذلك طائره
بيرقدار المسيره الترك
كلمه السر في افشال الهجوم الروسي البريه
على العاصمه كيا الاسابيع الاولى للحرب
الحصول عليهما الان يعني ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تتحضر لهجوم روسي اخر على
العاصمه من الشمال كما يعني فعاليه عاليه
في مواجهه التقدم البريه من الجهه
الجنوبيه الشرقيه في المعارك البريه لابد
من المدرعات الدفاعيه والهجوميه الدبابات
الثقيله والخفيفه وناقله الجن العود
الغربيه حتى الان تتحدث عن اعداد قليله من
هذه الدبابات ما يجعل فعاليتها في المعارك
مع حق اختبار معادله مسيرات تلك معادله
اثبتت جدوا بالنسبه للروس فضربوا بها
البنيه التحتيه الاخرانيه اكثر من مره
خصوصا بالمسيرات الايرانيه الصنع لذلك
تطالب اوكرانيا الغرب بمثل هذه المسيرات
المتوفره لدى معظم الدول الغربيه اذا ما
حصلت عليها اوكرانيا يعني انها ستكون
قادره على استهداف نقاط التجمع القوات
الروسيه على الارض وضرب العمق الروسيه اذا
ما وصلت قبل اسقاطها بالاضافه قدرتها على
ضرب رادارات العدو ومحطات اتصالاته لكن
هذه المسيرات ستبقى صيدا سهله الا اذا رفع
مستوى التكنولوجيا المزوده بها لتكون اكثر
دقه في الاصابه واكثر قدره على الهروب هذا
ما تحتاجه اوكرانيا لقلب المعادله القتال
فمع اقتراب الحرب من انهاء عامها الاول لم
يتمكن اي من الطرفين من حسم المعركه
حول هذا الموضوع معنا من موسكو يفداني في
دوروف عضو مجلس الدومه الروسي ومن مدينه
سانتدارس في اسبانيا فابريس بوتشي مديره
تخطيط السياسات السابق ومرحبا بكم في دروف
كيف تسير المعارك وفق الخطط كما يقول
الرئيس الروسي والجيش الروسي غير قادر حتى
الان بعد سبيع من القتال عن حسن المعارك
في باخموت نبل يحتاج الى الاستعانه بقوته
فاجنر لاحرازي تقدم منه هناك
القوات
هي شركه حربيه خاصه تقوم
بعمليات هجوميه في مواقع محدده هذه
العمليه العسكريه التابعه للقوات الروسيه
بشكل عام
لم نستخدم واحد بالمئه من قواتنا العسكريه
بعد
ليس من اهداف روسيا احتلال اوكرانيا انا
اوكرانيا حسب القوانين الدوليه هي منطقه
غير موجوده بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
لذلك ليس لدينا هدف احتلال اوكرانيا
لدينا هدف تشكيل حكومه هناك لا تهدد
الاراضي الروسيه وهذه هي الاستراتيجييه
المستخدمه من قبل القوات الروسيه نحن
لدينا عمليه عسكريه وليس حرب تظهر اصرار
روسيا على موقفها ونحن نفهم جيدا
الامريكاني
ان كان الامر كذلك سيدي فرجاني لماذا
يستمر القتال والمحاولات الروسيه للتقدم
عسكريه
نحن لا نحاول هذا حقيقه احنا نحن نحاول
اييه حل مشكله سلامه اراضي المواقع التي
انضمت لروسيا الفيدراليه اذن هي مهمه
محدوده
ليس همم نحن نحاول اعاده الاراضي والمناطق
التابعه
شعبيهتين
والوقت الذي يقول هذا سبب
اوكرانيا في نهايه النهايه روسيا سوف تحقق
جميع اهدافها نحن لم نشرك القوات النوويه
على سبيل المثال في المعارك لذلك الدول
التي همم تقدم من الاسلحه الاوكرانيا تعرض
اوكرانيا لازمه داخليه وهذا يتعارض مع
مصالح هذه الدول كما تحدثنا
كل الدعم المقدم اوكرانيا عسكريه
ما زالت القوات الروسيه بامكانها ان تحرز
تقدما على الارض ما تفكيرك لذلك
في البدايه اعتقد انه من الواضح ان روسيا
لديها عمق استراتيجيه حيث اننا نتحدث عن
ان لديها اراضي مؤمنه
لكي تتمكن من نشر القوات الروسيه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
واوكرانيا والتي لديها قوات مسلحه بعديدا
اقل لديها قدره على المقاومه وحتى على شان
عمليات هجوميه ولكنها تعتمد بشكل كبير على
القدرات العسكريه الغربيه وفي حقيقه الامر
تغير الموقف الغربي منذ الرابع والعشرين
من فبراير حتى اليوم من حيث الامدادات
العسكريه ولكن الاعداد لا تكفي
والنوعيه لا تكفي كي تتمكن اوكرانيا من
احداث الفرق
الدول الغربيه سترسل مزيدا من الاسلحه
الثقيله ما نوع هذه الاسلحه واي يفارق
يمكن ان تحدثه في المعارك
هنا عن الرد
على الجبهه الجديد التي فتحتها روسيا في
العاشره من اكتوبر وفي عطله نهايه الاسبوع
شاهدنا الضربات الصاروخيه الكبيره التي
استهدفت البنا التحتيه المدنيه الاوكرانيه
كردا على ذلك ان مجموعه من دول حلف شمال
الاطلسي بشكل اساسي فهمت ان القوات
الاوكرانيه بحاجه الى معدات
بكميات اكبر
وبنوعيه اعلى لحمايه المدنيين وايضا
لتحقيق
التقدم العسكري اعتقدوا ان هذه هي الفكره
الاساسيه حول ما سوف يعلن في ال 20 من
يناير في اجتماع ايران ستايل نتحدث هنا عن
تقديم الدبابات القتاليه سواء كانت
الخفيفه او الثقيله للقوات الاوكرانيه كي
تتمكن من الدفاع عن نفسها في مواجهه
التكتيك الذي يقضي بارتكاب جرائم حرب من
قبل الروس ولكن ايضا لاستعاده الاراضي
قلت لنا قبل قليل ان طول المعارك طول امد
المعارك على الارض والصعوبات ربما التي
تواجهها القوات الروسيه في بعض الاحيان
سببه الدعم المقدم من الناتو الى اوكرانيا
ولكن الموقف الرسمي الروسي يتحدث عن ان كل
هذا الدعم لا يحدث فارقا على الارض
صحيح تماما لان لدى روسيا اليات واذكر ان
لدى روسيا امكانيه نوويه عسكريه وهي
اقوى دول العالم في هذا المجال ولدينا
وسائل فعاله ومضمونه
لتحديد امريكا
في التسليح الغربي لاوكرانيا ان المشكله
الاساسيه التي تواجه التقدم الروسي هو
التسليح الغربي لاوكرانيا
ضروري
الماده اوكرانيا بالاسلحه والمال
وبالتوجيه والاداره هذه هي العقبه الاهم
ولكننا لم نكن نعلم هذا في البدايه عندما
بدانا في العمليه العسكريه وظهرت المشاكل
هذه من هذا النوع الان
وهذا طبعا
يزعج خططنا ويعيقها
وهذا قد يؤدي الى القيام باجراءات ضد
المناطق الامريكيه حتى نخرج امريكا من هذا
النزاع وهنا سوف تخبر تخسر عفوا
امريكاون يقوم يقومون بخطا كبير همم حيث
يفردون المنطق الامريكي على الاحداث
الاحداث التي سوف تؤدي الى دار ضد
الاقتصاد الامريكي ولم نخطط نحن لهذا انهم
هم من يطيل امل هذا انذاع يعني هل سيف همم
الدول الغربيه لدعمها لاوكرانيا عسكريا
يمكن ان نطور من هذا النزاع يمكن ان يمدده
نحو مناطق اخرى كما يقول السيد الجاني
اذا ما قدمنا الاسلحه المناسبه بالكميات
المناسبه هذه هي الطريقه الفضه لوضع حد
للحرب بشكل سريع لكي تاتي روسيا الى طاوله
المفاوضات من الواضح ان روسيا غير مهتمه
بالمفاوضات اليوم لذلك الطريقه الوحيده
لحل هذه الحرب التي شنتها روسيا هي من
خلال تامين الاسلحه الضروريه لاوكرانيا كي
تفهم روسيا بشكل لا لو [__] انه لا يمكنها
ان تستمر بالمضيق قدما وطريقه الوحيده هي
من خلال مفاوضات السياسيه
السابق في النيته وشكرا للسيد الجاني
اسمه فاجنر يتردد بكثره في جبهه الشرقيه
من حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا في فقره
المتابعه سنتوقف عند هذه الميليشيا ونسال
عن سياق نشاتها وعن اهدافها واسهامها في
الحرب
[موسيقى]
قتلت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الفلسطينيا
قرب بلده سلواد شرقيه مدينه رام الله
وتراجع جيش الاحتلال عن روايته الاولى
التي قال فيها ان الشهيد احمد كحله حاول
تنفيذ عمليه طعام دون اعطاء تفاصيل وتوالت
ردود الفعل الفلسطيني من السلطه والفصائل
التي تدين قتلى كحله
من المسافه صفر وحيث يقيم جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي حاجزا غير دائم عند المدخل
الغربي لبلده سلواد شرقيه رام الله اطلق
جنود الاحتلال رصاصه على الشهيد احمد
كحلان البالغ من العمر 45 عاما واصابته في
عنقه تنوعت روايات الجيش الاسرائيلي من
محاوله طعن الى خطف سلاح لكن شهود عيان
قدموا روايه مختلفه
في الناس فالناس الرايقه فصار زمره فبلشوا
في قنابل الصوت في السيارات
في سياره الشهيد فالشهيد يعني استفز شويه
فصي عليهم هجم على السياره على الشهيد
ونزلوا من السياره قدامي وادموه قدام بارد
مشهد تشييع الشهيد كحله الذي كان يعيد
اربعه من الابناء من رام الله الى مسقط
راسه في بلده رامون شرقي المدينه
ترتكبه اسرائيل في حق الفلسطيني
على شارع حوار الرئيسي جنوب نابلس في
الثاني من ديسمبر الماضي
وتفتح هذه الجرائم حسب الفلسطينيين الباب
امامهم لملاحظه اسرائيل قضائيا في المحاكم
الدوليه المختصه نحن نتبعها بشكل يومي
ومتتابع مع مكتب المدعي العام للجنائيه
الدوليه ونرفع له تقارير دوريه حول هذا
التصعيد في جرائم الاعدامات الميداليه
ونطالب الجنائيه الدوليه بسرعه الانتهاء
من تحقيق من تحقيقاتها وصولا لمساءله
ومحاسبه ومحاكمه مجرمي الحرب الاسرائيليين
استشهاده كحله واعدامه من مسافه السفر يدل
في راي الفلسطينيين على التيرباك لدى جنود
الاحتلال ويرونه ترجمه لسياسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده
الماضيه في استفسار اطلاق الرصاص على
الفلسطينيه
سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره رام الله فلسطين
في الخليل افاد شهود عيان ان مسلحين
فلسطينيين اطلقوا النار على حافله
للمستوطنين قرب بلده حلحول شمال المدينه
ثم انسحبوا من المكان من جهه قال جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان الحافله تتعرضت
لاضرار جراء اصابتها بعده ناريه دون وقوع
خسائر بشريه وقد دفع قوات الاحتلال
بتعزيزات الى المنطقه وباشرت عمليه تمشيطا
واسع
شهدت بلده يعبد جنوب غرب مدينه جنين
مواجهات تخللتها اشتباكات مسلحه بين
مقاومين فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي اقتحمت البلده لكن لم
يبلغ عن وقوع اصابات من الجانبين واكد
شهود عيان انسحاب قوات الاحتلال من البلده
في غضون ذلك اعتقلت قريته الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلال الساعات الماضيه ثمانيه
فلسطينيين بينهم اسرى محررون من مناطق
متفرقه بالضفه الغربيه والقدس المحتله
وقال نادي الاسير الفلسطيني ان عمليات
الاعتقال تركزات في مدن رام الله والخليل
وجنين والقدس ونقل المعتقلون الى مراكز
للتحقيق معهم في قضايا تتعلق بمقاومه
الاحتلال
من رام الله ينضم الينا الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادرات الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه مرحبا بك دكتور مصطفى منذ
بدايه هذا العام سقط اكثر من 13 شهيدا
وتوقل 190 شخصا من قبل الاحتلال نتحدث فقط
عن الضفه الغربيه والقدس ما رسائل
الاحتلال
ثلاثه منهم من الاطفال
واليوم جرت عمليه اغتيال اعدام ميداني
بشكل [__] من قبل الجيش الاحتلال للشهيد
احمد كحله
وفيما مثل مشهدا مشابها لمجره لعمار مفلح
قبل ذلك في حواره
الرساله ان ما نواجهه جيش فاشيء عنصري
اجرامي لا يتورى عن ارتكاب اي جريمه تجاه
فلسطين الرساله ان كل فلسطيني حياته في
خطر لا يوجد امن لاي فلسطيني في اي مكان
في الاراضي المحتله والرساله ان اسرائيل
لا تفهم الا لغه القوه والشعب الفلسطيني
يفهم ذلك الان انه لا يستطيع ان يحمي نفسه
الا بمقاومه هذا الاحتلال المجرم بمقاومه
هذه الحكومه الفاشيه العنصريه الاسوء في
تاريخ المنطقه على الاطلاق
ولا يستطيع ان يحمي نفسه الا بايضا ان
يقرر ان المقاومه بم لعبه واسعه على
الصعيد الدولي لفضل العقوبات والمقاطعه
على هذه الحكومه الفاشيه العنصريه
همم
يعني وتصرف الاحتلال مع الفلسطينيين بهذا
الشكل وبهذا العنف الى اين يمكن ان يؤدي
دكتور
انفجار شامل نحن اصلا نعيش حاله تشبه
الانتفاضه الى حد كبير بل هي حاله انتفاضه
تجري على شكل موجات ااه
تتصاعد الاحداث في بئر مختلفه من وقت الى
اخر بلميه وانا برايي ان انا على درب
سيؤدي في الواقع الانفجار الانتفاض شامل
لانه الشعب الفلسطيني باسره الان معرض
للخطر ولا يمكن الا ان يتكاتف بكل مكوناته
في لحمه واحده تواجه هذا الاحتلال المجرم
ما يقوم به الاسرائيليون من تصعيد ليس فقط
ضد الفلسطينيين في الاراضي المحتله يقوم
ايضا بتصعيد خطير في الداخل في اراضي ال
ويقوم بعمليات استفزاز خطيره سنرى امثله
لها في المسجد الاقصى
سنرى امثله لها في عمليات القمع للاسرى
والاسيرات في سجون الاحتلال لذلك انا براي
ما يجري هو وصف الانفجار شامل
انه ان ال
قناعه تتعمق بشكل غير مسبوق بان
اسرائيليون لا يفهم الا لغه القوه وعلينا
ان نقاومهم اما الاستمرار داخل اسرائيل
والدكتور مصطفى باعتقادك والذي يعني نرى
فيه انقساما حادا بين هذه الحكومه الحاليه
والكثير من مكونات همم المكونات
الاسرائيليه والمعارضه الاسرائيليه كيف من
شانه باعتقادك ان ينعكس على سلوك
الاسرائيلي اتجاه الفلسطيني
هناك ظاهرتان تجريان بشكل متوازي من ناحيه
هناك هجمه فاشيه على الشعب الفلسطيني ومن
ناحيه اخرى هناك حاله تفتت داخلي
اسرائيليه طبعا لانه في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي هناك صراع حاد الان يجري لانه
كثيرون بداوا يكتشفوا رغم عدائهم ايضا
للفلسطينيين ان هذه الحكومه فاشيه وستلحق
بهم همم كيهود ايضا اضرار كبيره هناك هجوم
على القضاء في اسرائيل هناك هجوم على
التشريعات نحن نتحدث عن حكومه اسرائيليه
فاسده بالكامل فيها عنصري مجرمين الفرشيين
مثل ابن كبير بس مطريش وهي تجر المنطقه
الى وضع خطير لكن التفتت الداخلي
الاسرائيلي انا براي عنصر مساعد
للفلسطينيين في كشف وتعريه هذا النظام
العنصري البغيض وفي مطالبه العالم بفرض
العقوبات والمقاطعه عليه وليست التستر
عليه علينا ان تذكر ان هذا التطرف الفاشل
العنصري لم يكن ليحدث بهذه الدرجه لولا
صمت المجتمع الدولي على جرائم اسرائيل
شكرا جزيلا لكم رام الله الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادرات الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
في تطورات الازمه السياسيه في تونس سيعيد
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل الى الواجهه
مخاطر الانسداد السياسي وتداعياته
اجتماعيا واقتصاديا حيث حذر الامين العام
المساعده لاتحاد من مخاطر انتفاضه الشعبيه
بسبب التراجع الناجح عن خيارات الحكومات
المتعاقبه وسياساتها التي وصفها بغير
الشرعيه
[موسيقى]
بمصار الرئيس في تونس رغم الانتقادات
والتحفظات وحتى المقاطعه فقد اعلنت هيئه
الانتخابات ان الدوره الثانيه للانتخابات
التشريعيه سيجرى في التاسعه والعشرين من
الشهر الجاري بعد اكتمال كافه التحضيرات
في اعضاء مجلس النواب لسنه 2022 يوم
الاثنين في 2023 وكان عدد الناخبين
المسجلين في دوري الاول قد وصل الى اكثر
من تسعه ملايين نابب لكن نسبه المشاركه
كانت متدنيه وهو ما اسفر عن فوزي 23 مرشحا
فقط بما قاعده في البرلمان في الدور الاول
لتعاد الانتخابات في اكثر من 130 دائره في
الدور الثاني
بالتزامني مع ذلك ترتفع الاصوات المحذره
من مخاطر المسار الذي تسير فيه البلاد حيث
يقود الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل وهو
اكبر نقابات البلاد مع منظمه اخرى من
بينها عباده المحامين مباحثات الساعيه
لاعداد مقترح مبادره سياسيه يهدف الى
انهاء الازمه السياسيه والاجتماعيه لكن
الاتحاد في الوقت ذاته يحذر من وقوع ما
يسميها بعد قادته ثوره شعب افترته سياسه
الحكومه المتعقبه
شخصيه
[موسيقى]
الى اقتراح مبادرات للخروج من الازمه في
وقت ترتفع فيه مطالب المعارضه وعلى راسها
جبهه الخالص الوطني بتنحي رئيس الجمهوريه
وتنظيم الانتخابات الرئاسيه سابقه لاوانها
وتكليف حكمتهم
تقف البلاد اليوم على مفترق طرق سعيا
للخروج من ازمات مركبه لا يبدو حلها يسيرا
ولا وشيكا في ظل تمسك كل طرف بمواقفه ما
يزيد المخاوف من تداعيات استمرارها سياسيا
واقتصاديا
واجتماعيا حافظ الجزيره تونس
اتحاد الشغل في تونس من خطوره ملالات
الازمه السياسيه مع بدء نقاشات بشان
مبادره انقاذ ساعه الاتحاد الى الدفع بها
بالتنسيق مع قوى المدنيه اخرى حيث اعلن
الامين العام الاتحاد الشغل نور الدين
الطبوبي في اواخر ديسمبر الماضي انطلاقه
مشاورات من اجل اتفاق على تشكيل مبادره
لاخراج تونس من الازمه السياسيه الحاليه
مبادره الانقاذ كما يصطلح عليها اعلاميا
لم يعلن عن تفاصيلها لكن وفقا لتصريح عميد
المحامين حاتم المزيو فانها تقترح اصلاحا
شاملا في المجلات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
والسياسيه على يتم تقديمها وعرضها على قيس
سعيد باعتباره صاحب شرعيه انتخابيه وفي
اخر تصريح من الامين العام المساعد لاتحاد
الشغل حفيظ الذي رجح ان تتعلق محاور
المبادره للانتخابات التشريعيه في دورها
الاول وامكانيه المرور الى اجراء نقابات
الرئاسيه مبكره وتعديل الدستور والقانون
الانتخابي ثم المرور الى انتخابات تشريعيه
اضافه الى مناقشه اقرار اجراءات عاجله من
ضمنها تكوين حكومه كفاءات وطنيه لها مهام
محدده تستجيب لطبيعه المرحله وتشمل
المبادره بشكل رئيسي صاحب المبادره اتحاد
الشغل وعماده المحامين والرابطه التونسيه
للدفاع عن حقوق الانسان والمنتدى التونسي
للحقوق الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه واكدت
قيادات في اتحاد الشغل لان المبادره
الحاليه رغم عدم اكتمال تفاصيلها فانه لا
يمكن ان تكون شبيهه بالحوار الوطني لسنه
2013 بسبب اختلاف الظرفيه
من جهه اخرى نقلت وكاله الانباء التونسيه
الرسميه عن محي الدين لاغا الكاتب العام
لرابطه حقوق الانسان وعضو وفد الرابطه
المشارك في اجتماعات لبلوره مشروع مبادره
انقاذ للبلاد ان رئاسه الجمهوريه لم
تتفاعل بعد مع مبادره المنظمات الوطنيه
للانقاذ رغم نداءات الامين العام لاتحاد
الشغل ورئيس رابطه حقوق الانسان
ينضم الينا من تونس صالح عطيه الكاتب
الصحفي ومن تونس ايضا بالحسن اليحياوي
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بكما سيد
بلحسن كيف يمكن ان يتفاعل الرئيس قيس سعيد
مع هذه المبادره التي
يطرحها من بين من يطرحها الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل
نعم يا اختي الحقيقه يبقى الاتحاد العام
التونسي الشغل الطرف الاكثر الذي يحظى
باكبر قدر من مصداقيه ربما في الشارع
التونسي بعد ان فقد شراء تونسي في قطعه
طبعا في الاحزاب السياسيه
وايضا
استيائه من مسار قيس سعيد كان يعني
ارتفاعا مضطرب الان الاتحاد
[موسيقى]
ايضا اجراءات اقتصاديه واجتماعيه في تطور
ان هذه المبادره تاتي متاخره جدا لانه جاء
اعتقد ان الرئيس سعيد كانت قد يستجيب الى
هذه المبادره نظرا لانه الان وقع تحديد
الموعد لاجراء الدوله الثانيه للانتخابات
التشريعيه وباجراء الدوله الثانيه
للانتخابات التشريعيه وانتصار البرلمان
تنتهي حاله الاستثناء والمفروض عند انتهاء
حاله الاستثناء ان تكون هناك التحويرات
كبرى وايضا اقامه جمله من المؤسسات
الدستوريه اساسا المحكمه الدستوريه
وايضا المجلس القضاء بتصوره الجديد فلا
اعتقد ان الرئيس قد يستجيب لاي مبادره
يكون فيها شق سياسي ماء
ماذا عن المعارضه كيف يمكن ان تتفاعل مع
مبادره الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
مساء الخير يا اسيل اليك والى مشاهديكي
الكرام الى ضيفك الاستاذ بالاحسن اعتقد ان
المعارضه واضحه في موقفها هي تدعو بالعكس
من ذلك تدعو الاتحاد ان يكون الطرفا فاعلا
في الحل السياسي القادم ولكن الاتحاد هو
الذي يرفض هذه المعارضه ويصنفها يتعامل مع
بعضها في شكل الخماسي ولكن مع جبهه خلاص
الوطني
اليوم فكره الانتخابات الرئاسيه على خلفيه
نتائج الدوري الثاني من الانتخابات
التشريعيه اعتقد الذي خطوه اذا مضى فيها
الاتحاد معنى ذلك انه همم يعني وضع نفسه
خارج خريطه رئيس الجمهوريه لاول مره في
الاولا ثم انه من ناحيه ثانيه سيدخل في
معترك جديد في صراعا مع رئيس الجمهوريه من
للانتخابات فريق اسيا المبكره وبالتالي
سيجد بالضروره نفسه امام ضروره الالتقاء
مع جبه خلاص الوطني بشكل من الاشكال فمن
اجنده معينه ضمن نداء مشترك معه يعني بين
الطرفين من اجل الموفي قدما في اتجاه حل
سياسي للمازق الحالي في تونس خارج هذا
السياق في تقديم كل الاتحاد ان يتقدم ق
يده مادام متشبثا بانه من يصف 25 يوليو هو
كان خلال هو خارج الحمار الوطني
جاءت ربما متاخره لانه جرت الان الدعوه
الى الدوره الثانيه من الانتخابات ولكن
السؤال ماذا لو كان الاقبال على هذه
الدوره بنفس الاقبال المنخفض في الدوره
الاولى كيف يمكن ان تتعاطى رئاسه
الجمهوريه مع هذا الامر
الحقيقه يعني نسبه الاقبال ليس لها اي
تاثير قانوني ليس لها اي اثر قانوني على
نتائج الانتخابات مهما كانت نسبه الاقبال
وما كان عدد المشتركين في هذه الانتخابات
تلقائيا
النتيجه باعتقادك سيد بلحسن يعني عندما
يعني عندما تلامس النسبه ال 10% او اقل
تؤثر على مشروعيه
البرلمان على اعتبار
يعني يجب الحصول عليها للدخول الى
البرلمان وبالتالي هذا البرلمان سينتصبوا
به 130 مهما كانت نسبه المشاركه في الدوري
الثاني للانتخابات الان طبعا المشاركه
المتدنيه تفتح الباب واسع للطعام في هذا
البرلمان وربما تشجع المعارضه على التشبه
في مواقفها وعلى الوقوف في موقفها الذي لم
تتحرك منه قيد امه لمده
نظر لان هذا على نفس الارضيه المناسبات
التي تعالج والرئيس سعيد ولا مع الرئيس
السيسي طيب على اعتبار ان الاتحاد يسر على
ان العوده الى ما قبل 25 هجريه امر غير
ممكن تماما
خيارات المعارضه الان ويبدو ان كل
تحركاتها ودعواتها تقابل بالصمت من قبل
رئيس الجمهوريه لا بل حتى يبدو انه ماض في
مساره بالدعوه اليوم في اعقاب التظاهرات
التي شهدتها تونس بالامس الدعوه اليوم
للدوره الثانيه من الانتخابات التشريعيه
الحوار الوطني الاجتماعيه وفي مقدمات
اتحاد الشغل ولا من المعارضه رئيس مازن في
مشروعي وسيمضي فيه الى اخر رمق منقل
بالنسبه لذلك شخصيا نعتبر انه الحل
الاساسي اليوم في تونس دستوري لا نقاشه
فيه وهناك سياسي لانه الحوار الوطني
بعد الاطراف السياسيه اليوم تونس مطروح
عليها ان تمضي باتجاه ما يمكن ان نسميه
بالكتله التاريخيه وهي التي تتالف من جبهه
الخلاص وما يمكن ان يكون معها ومن بعض
الاطراف الدوليه على راسه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والاتحاد الاوروبي خاصه
باعتبار شركتنا كانت تونس مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي بالاضافه الى القوه الصلبه
المؤسسه العسكريه والامنيه من اجل الخروج
بحل السياسي في تونس في كامل السالميه
وبتكمل الهدوء في اطار حوار شامل لهذا
الموضوع
الكاتب الصحفي والسيد بن حسن اليحيوي
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من تونس
[موسيقى]
في ليبيا وصل المبعوث الخاص الامم المتحده
عبد الله باتلي الى مدينه سرت لرعايه جوله
جديده من اجتماعات لجنه العسكريه المشتركه
خمسه زائد خمسه ويعد استئناف انشطه هذه
اللجنه من اولويات الباتيلي منذ تعيينه
شهر سبتمبر الماضي حيث ستركز المباحثات
بشان توحيد المؤسسه العسكريه الليبيه
وانهاء حاله الانقسام من جانبا اخر كشفت
مصادر ليبيه للجزيره ان مديره سي اي اي
نيكولاس شدد خلال زيارته الى ليبيا على
عدم المساسه بموانئ النفط او بتصديره
تمثل لجنه العسكريه خمسه زائد خمسه المسار
العسكريه لنتائج مؤتمر برلين بشان ليبيا
وخلص الى ثلاثه مسارات سياسي واقتصادي
وعسكري تتكون اللجنه من خمسه عسكريين
يمثلون الجهه الغربيه لليبيا وخمسه اخرين
يمثلون القوات التي يقودها خليفه حفتر
مهمه اللجنه وفق نتائج مؤتمر برلين هي
العمل على تحقيق اتفاق وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار وتسهيل العوده الامنه للمدنيين الى
مناطقهم اضافه الى اخراج المقاتلين
الاجانب والمرتزقه بدا من فبراير عام 2020
عقدت اللجنه عده جوالات مباحثات وصولا الى
اخر جوله عقدت في مدينه سررت شهر اكتوبر
الماضي خلال هذه الجوالات كان الهدف
النهائي للمباحثات هو توحيد المؤسسه
العسكريه الليبيه لبناء جيش قوي بعيدا عن
التجاذبات السياسيه من خلال انشاء
لهذا الغرض الان يسعى مبعوث الامم المتحده
الجديد الى ليبيا سنغالي عبد الله باتيلي
لتحريك المياه الراكده في مساعي توحيد
المؤسسه العسكريه الليبيه فقد وصل الى
مدينه سرت لرعايه جوله جديده من اجتماعات
اللجنه وقالت البعثه الامميه انها ستكون
بحضور مراقبي وقفه اطلاق النار الليبيين
والدوليين انها خطوه مهمه بالنسبه للشركاء
الدوليين الذين يراقبون تطور الوضع الليبي
فحسب مصادر للجزيره شدد مدير وكاله
المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه ويليامبرز
خلال لقائه الاخير برئيس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه عبد الحميد طبيبه على ان المرحله
التي تعيشها ليبيا يجب ان تكون انتقاليه
ونهائيه وبعيده عن اي مسارات سياسيه
المسؤول الامريكي الذي زار ليبيا نهايه
الاسبوع الماضي حذر خليفه حفتر في بن غازي
من المساث بموانئ النفط الاولى وقال ان
واشنطن تريد استقرار قطاع النفط الليبي
وعدم وقف تصديره كما حدث في مره سابقه
صباح اليوم الاحد مع كارثه انسانيه اودت
بحياته 68 شخصا بعد تحطم طائره في مقاطعه
بكاره وسط البلاد الطائره كانت تحمل 72
راكبا بينهم 15 اجنبيا وقد اعلنت الحكومه
نيباليه تشكيله لجنه التحقيق
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
سوفت وير الاسرائيليه فازت بمناقصه لبيع
برامج تجسس لشركه اتصالات المدعومه من
الدوله
قبل شهر من الانقلاب العسكري الذي وقع في
فبراير شباط عام 2020 وافادت شكوى قانونيه
قدمت مؤخرا الى المدعي العام الاسرائيلي
وكشف عنها النقاب اليوم بان الصفقه اجرمت
رغم ادعاء اسرائيل ايقافها نقل
التكنولوجيا الدفاعيه الى ميانمار عقب
حكما للمحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه عام 2017
وطالبت الشكوى باجراء تحقيق جنائي بشان
الصفقه منتهمه شركه
الدفاع والخارجيه بالمساعده على ارتكاب
جرائم ضد الانسانيه في ميانمار والتحريض
عليها
وقعت قبائل اقليم النيل الازرق الجنوبي
السودان اتفاقا للتعايش السلمي بحضور رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان في مدينه
الدمازين ونص الاتفاق على نبذ العنف ووقف
خطاب الكراهيه والعنصريه واعتبار اتفاقي
جوبا مرجعيه للاتفاق الحلي وحل النزاعات
القبليه عبر الادارات الاهليه كما نص
الاتفاقه على انشاء نيابات ومحاكمه خاصه
بقضايا النزاع القبلي وتوفير المساعدات
الانسانيه لعوده النازحين والاحتكام
لقوانين الحكم الاتحادي واحترام التنوع
الثقافي وكان اقليم النيل الازرق قد شهد
عنفا قبليا الدال مقتل اكثر من 200 شخص
بين يوليو واكتوبر الماضي
ونبقى في السودان حيث يعاني الالاف من
مصابي ثوره ديسمبر ظروفا صحيه صعبه فقمتها
تعقيدات حصولهم على الرعايه الصحيه
اللازمه والطر عدد كبير من المصابين الى
اجراء عمليات جراحيه خارج البلاد بسبب
ندره بعض التخصصات الطبيه في الداخل
اصابهها بطلق الناري في الساق خلال
مشاركتها في المظاهرات الشعبيه فرضت عليها
واقعا جديده تشكو من ارتفاع مستمر في
تكاليف العلاج وتعجز عن التحرك للعوده الى
عملها كمعلمه
واطلع سلم صعبه وانزل المصطبه ذات التكلفه
بتاعت مشيتي من هنا للمدرسه لقيتها مكلفه
شديد
قصه رينان تضاف اليها قصص اخرى تجسد
احداها الحاله الذي وصل اليه مدثر بجسد
النصف مشلول يقابل الحياه منذ ثلاثه اعوام
وفي سبيل ان يعود قادرا على الحركه خضع
لعمليات جراحيه عده لكن دون جدوره
ما قال اليه حال مدثر والالاف من مصاب
الثوره ديسمبر وتعثر مشاريع علاجهم
يستدعيان تدخل من الدوله حسب اللجان
الطبيه الخاصه بالمصابين
اطراف عندنا ناس موعدين مشلولين
بيئه ممكن تليق بعلاجه
ولتحقيق هذا الهدف يعتصم هؤلاء امام مجلس
الوزراء ممثلون لمصابي ثوره ديسمبر
يطالبون بانصاف المصابين والتوفير الرعايه
الطبيه اللازمه لهم لكن ضعف التمويل يحول
دون ذلك
فيه كميه من الملفات الماء المنظمه يعني
الحكايه منظمه اكثر همم
السفر منظم اكثر لكن طبعا ال- همم يعني
الريسورس او الموارد له
يتكرر هذا المشهد كثيرا خلال المظاهرات
الشعبيه
القنابل الصوتيه والغاز المسير للدموع
غالب ما تخلف اصابات متفاوته وسط
المتظاهرين فعدد الاصابات تجاوز الالاف
منذ القرارات التي اعلن عنها رئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان في ال 25 من
اكتوبر الماضي وحلى بموجبها مجلس الوزراء
والسياده لا تخرج تظاهره شعبيه مطالبه
لسلطه مدنيه في البلاد دون التذكير بقضيه
مصاب الثوره ملف يامل اصحابه ان يبقى
مفتوحا امام الراي العام والمنظمات
الحقوقيه لا سيما ان عددهم اصبح بالالاف
حسب اللجنه المعنيه بمصاب الثوره نزار
البقداوي الجزيره الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
عوده الى حربي اوكرانيا حيث يتعزز دور
مليشيا الروسيه في تلك الحرب بعد تكبدي
موسكو خسائر ميدانيه مرتفعه فما هي خريطه
انتشار فاجنر هناك تقدر الولايات المتحده
حاليا عدد مرتزقه فاجنر في اوكرانيا بنحو
50 الفن ينتشر معظمهم في الشرق البلاد
ويعتمد الجيش الروسي منذ اشهر على هؤلاء
المقاتلين في اجزاء
اكثر الجبهات سخونه حاليا هي مدينه
سوليدار التي تنفذ وتؤكد موسكو تحت
السيطره الروسيه وقد صرح قاده ميدانيون من
فاجنر ان مقاتليليهم شنه هجوما مباغتا على
محورين واقتحموا وسط المدينه بعد انقطع
طرق الامداد عن القوات الاوكرانيه في
مدينه باخبط الاستراتيجيه على بعد نحو 15
كم من سوليدار كانت قوته فاجنر قد معارك
تكبدت فيها خسائر كبيره ويتهم مسؤولون
امريكيون مجموعه فاجنر بالسعي الى السيطره
على مناجم الملح والجبس في تلك المنطقه
ووفقه تلك المعطيات فان من المرجح ان
تنخرط فاجنر في المعارك المقبله ولا سيما
في جبهه كرامات تورسك المرشحه للتصعيد
ميليشيا فاغننري هي منظمه روسيه شبه
عسكريه اقرب الى وكاله خاصه لتعاقد
العسكري مملوكه لرجل الاعمال يفديني بريجن
المقرب من الكرملين وتتشكل من الاف
السجناء الروس الذين قابلوا القتال مقابل
محكوميهاتهم
اسس بريقه
عام 2014 لتشارك في القتال في حرب دوم باس
باوكرانيا الى جانب القوات الانفصاليه في
دنياك ولوجان في اواخر اكتوبر
2015 ابلغ لاول مره عن وجود متعاقدين
عسكريين في سوريا بعد نحو شهر من التدخل
العسكري الروسي الى جانب نظام الاسد في
اكتوبر عام 2018 قالت المخابرات
البريطانيه انه تم انشاء قاعدتين عسكريتين
روسيتين في بنغازي وتبرق شرقيه ليبيا لدعم
حفتر وتعزز ذلك عندما شاركت مليشياته
فاجنر في هجومه الفاشله على العاصمه
طرابلس تفيد تقارير غربيه بان فاجنر في
محاولتين على الاقل لاغتيال الرئيس
الاوكراني فولودي ميرسي قبل ان تدخل
الميليشي على خط القتال وتصبح راس ح للجيش
الروسي في اوكرانيا ويرجح ان انفاق فاجنر
لتمويل عملياتها في اوكرانيا لا يقل عن
100 مليون دولار شهريا وقد خضعت المجموعه
لعقوبات اوروبيه وامريكيه بدون ما
ترتكابها انتهاكات خطيره في سوريا وليبيا
واوكرانيا حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك عمي دنيا هل يعني
تقدم فاجنر في سوليدار وظهور يفجان
بريكوجان اليوم هناك ان هي من استطاعت ان
تحسم المعارك بينما اخفق الجيش الروسي في
ذلك
السي هناك الصراع يبدو بين وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه
وممول شركه فاجنر بيكوجين
وكانه يريد ان ياخذ كل الحصه هي تقول
كلا القوات المجوقله او المحموله هي التي
ساعدت فعلا قوات بالسيطره على سوليدار ولم
تنتهي حتى الان سوليدار اليوم هذه الشركه
همم هي شركه ليست معترف فيها بالقانون
الروسي اثنين الاهم ال سي انه يقال انه
تعيين جرسيموف وزير رئيس الاركان كقائد
مكان سيرفيكين وتعيين سيروفين مساعد له
كان بسبب قرب فاجنر او قرب بريكوجين من
هذا القائد والتماهي بينهما وكانه يريد
الرئيس بوتين بطريقه غير مباشره اعاده
السيطره على هذه المجموعه ليقول الامر لي
يعني نحن نعلم من تاريخ ال ال
الصراعات التي انخرطت فيها فاجنر انه لم
يظهر بشكل اعتيادي بريجوجل ما الرساله
اليوم من وراء ظهوره في سوليدار وتوجيهه
واطلاقه تصريحات همم للاوكرانيين
في ليبيا في مالي في السودان وفي سوريا
وحتى في الدوبامباز لم تكن الدوله فعلا
تعترف بهذه الشركه مؤخرا فقط لمره واحده
ذكرت وزاره الدفاع انها بالتعاون مع
بيغوجين او مع فاجنر تم السيطره على
سوليدار اليوم عندما يظهر الرئيس يظهر
ممول الشركه في الجنازات على خط المعارك
على الجبهه يقول انا موجود ولكن هذا امر
يتطلب او يطلب بطريقه غير مباشره شرعانت
سوليدار شرعا انت همم في القانون الروسي
وبالتالي المكاسب السياسيه والترجمه لها
في المرحله القادمه من ومن يقول انه قد
يكون في مركز عالي في حال لو تبدلت كل
الاوضاع داخل الروسيه
حاجه الجيش الروسي لهذه علمي اشياء من اجل
احراز تقدم كالذي حدث سولدار
نوعيه المقاتل نوعيه التجهيزات وعدم
مسؤوليه الرئيس بوتين في الداخل الروسي هي
مهمه له اذا قتل احدهم هو متعاقد وليس جيش
من الجيش العادي يؤثر في الداخل الروسي
لديهم خبره لديهم تجهيزات عسكريه ولديهم
اموال وضمانات لعائلاتهم هذا الامر يسهل
هذه العمليه خاصه ان حرب المدن هي اعقد
الحروب واصعب الحروب على الاطلاق ال سي
جزيلا لك العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من بيروت
[موسيقى]
عواصف الشديده امطار غير مسبوقه فيضانات
انهيارات ارضيه انزلاقات طينيه وخسائر
بشريه هذا هو الوضع في ولايه كاليفورنيا
الامريكيه التي اعلنت فيها حاله الكارثه
الكبرى الاعاصير دمرت المنازل وقطعت
الكهرباء عن عشرات الالاف في جنوب شرق
الولايات المتحده لا دليل على وجود رابط
مباشر بين التغير المناخي وسلسله العواصف
والعاصير هذه لكن العلماء يحذرون بانتظام
من ان الاحترار يزيد من وتيره الظواهر
المناخيه القصوى وحدتها تعقد لاتفاقيات
تتوالد تعهدات ولا تتوقف التحذيرات لكن
الانشطه الضاره بكوكبنا تتواصل معها توتر
ظواهر الطقس المتطرف والامل كل الامل ان
يحدث التصالح المامول بين يعني والبيئه
ونتجنب ما هو اسود ختام وحصاد هذه الليله
مشاهدينا الكرام ننتقل الان الى جوله
منتصف الليل مع الزميلين سلمى الجمل
وعثمان اي فرح في جوله منتصف الليل اذا
شكرا لمتابعتكم حصاد هذه الليله والى
اللقاء